welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in jake paul reportedly has his next
opponent in line and it may be as tough
as yet according to a report from
nosmokeboxing.com and later confirmed by
tmz sports paul will face legendary ufc
fighter anderson silva in a showtime
pay-per-view on october 29th the 47 year
old silva beat tito ortiz in the ring
last september and has a victory over
julio cesar chavez jr son of the former
wbc middleweight champion nate diaz had
some fun with an usada sample collector
who showed up to diaz's house to take a
urine sample ahead of diaz's september
10th bout at ufc 280 with tamzat
shimayev after failing to provide the
usada agent with enough urine diaz
decided to hop on instagram live and
smoke weed while he and the agent waited
until diaz could provide more urine
this man
this man won't get out of my house
because i didn't give him enough piss
i pissed all i can my money
[Laughter]
how many leaders do i gotta do
i got two more liters of piss i gotta
give him and he won't get out of here
until
my guy but you sounded like a [ __ ]
sucker dick
come back in six hours i'll give you two
more
come on what leaders middle ladies
never change nate hamza chemaya recently
spoke with fcr mma about his upcoming
fight with nate diaz according to
chemiev if you wanted to he could just
wait for a title shot but took the fight
with diaz to show that diaz is not as
good as he is famous i could wait like
for the title and all i just waiting i
don't know the top three and uh just
have to wait but i took the fight a guy
is not
but he's famous you know like everyone
loves him like everyone talk about this
gangster that
brother gonna come where i eat the
greg's for the breakfast you know like
paulo costa suffered some injuries
during his war with luke rockhold at ufc
279 and he will need surgery costa
revealed on his youtube channel that he
broke his hand during the fight and the
recovery process could take up to two
months i broke my hand in the fight i
thought i had a bone injury or maybe
ligaments but what really happened was a
fracture to the metacarpal bone i hoped
it wasn't a fracture because then i
would be able to come back to fighting
again in 50 or 60 days and use all the
conditioning in the whole camp i've done
initially after the fight costa was
looking for a quick turnaround to get
his last fight on contract in before the
new year now those plans may be in
jeopardy i plan on fighting in 60 days
but it won't be possible i'll have to
fight in december or january we'll have
a ufc card in rio so maybe it happens
there it's up to the ufc last week
darren till spoke about his plans to
return to the octagon after dealing with
injuries and included that he still
plans to be a world champion one day
despite being 1-3 in his last four
fights till still has self-confidence
and also has the confidence of legendary
uk fighter michael bisping on his
youtube channel bisping law to till and
believes he will be a world champion
darren till you're laughing at me
because he's 1-3 in his last four darren
till will be champion one day his
striking is phenomenal his mind is
strong he's just had a bit of a bad run
and again 29 years old he'll be champ
bisping then went on to praise all the
uk fighters and said the uk will have
multiple champions people seem to think
i'm salty that leon won i am over the
god damn moon for leon and i support
every fighter from the uk of course i
wasn't going to be the first and only
one we're going to have a slew of
champions coming from the uk tom
aspinall as we know sadly hurt his leg
but tom will be champion he will be back
he's going to rehab he's going to have
the surgery he's going to be coming back
six months nine months maybe a year but
he's only 29 years old and he will be
champion of the heavyweight division
make no mistake mark my words on episode
283 of the weighing in podcast with josh
thompson and big john mccarthy the pair
also chimed in on till's comments about
his return big john said that while he
enjoys till as a fighter and is excited
to see him compete again he would just
like to see the return actually happen
before hearing talk about being the
champ
first i love darren till's personality i
love daryn tillo as a fighter i think
his personality he's fantastic he's
funny
uh he's he's got a ton going for him he
just seems to have right now
you know every time that he's starting
to get ready for a fight
something bad happens he gets hurt he's
getting that you know
almost the label of a little bit brittle
and he's not able to get himself to the
fight
that's really what it's going to be he's
saying you know i want two fights that's
great
let's get one
let's get one in right now you know and
not worry about
getting to in
get yourself to the show get yourself to
the fight
and let's see if the comeback is on but
like he's a good fighter and like i said
he's a personality he's funny he's you
know
he's uh entertaining as a fighter so
just get to the fight man on one
championships one on prime video one
card last friday demetrius johnson
knocked out adriano marias in a rematch
for the flyweight title johnson's
victory evened the score at one a piece
in his first statement since the loss
marias congratulated johnson in a tweet
and shared he is ready for a trilogy
alright i'm okay congratulations to
mighty mouse and thank you for a great
fight it was honor share the circle
again with you see you in a trilogy
match 1x1 after the fight demetrius
johnson facetimed henry cejudo to
celebrate the victory despite the pair
being rivals during their ufc days they
have now formed a friendship and cejudo
even trained with johnson for this
upcoming bout the facetime call was
shared on cejudo's personal twitter
what's up man and uh
yeah gassing up but saying good things
about you and uh
you know it was very
very appreciative for allowing me to
come out and uh get some work with you
you know even though it was a week two
weeks just to
balance things off five out and just you
know
i guess when i came to train with you
and you're like dude you're nasty you're
not clenching it's like okay i'm gonna
stay with the clinch you know and then
even
remember what i told you i said that's
your greatest gift your greatest gift is
your knees bro this is why when we
practice i'm like i can see why
for the longest the pros like this
[ __ ] just happened to catch me
in a white i was like he catch me you
know on the wrong way because like no
this dude's got skills in that area you
know what i'm saying in fact i mean you
see it now demetrius and you're right
you're 36 years old and you're you're
still getting better because there's
areas that i i do want to go over with
you
um you're always trying to go over
something
i'm constantly you know i'm constantly
you know it's the scientist it's the
scientists you know what i mean yeah
good stuff well enjoyment
congratulations to me it means a lot
that you even call bro i was just about
to send you a message too but you even
made it even better like you got uncle
michael recording looking for more
original mma content check out the rest
of thick boy youtube exclusive
interviews opinion and fight analysis is
available weekly on the shob show food
truck diaries and fight night flashbacks
subscribe so you don't miss any of the
action